bonjour à tous et leurs deux par le
break doboj à catllar bonjour michael
est notre invité cette semaine aurélie
filippetti bonjour vous êtes députée
socialiste de moselle membre de la
commission des finances et ancien
ministre de la culture beaucoup
d'actualité pour vous cette semaine on
va commencer par la droite deuxième
débat de la primaire des échanges plutôt
musclé et des piques contre nicolas
sarkozy alain juppé lui reste le favori
des sondages et on parlera aussi des
tensions dans le couple exécutif les
sous-entendus et petites phrases se sont
multipliées par médias interposés entre
un président sortant qui entretient le
suspense sur ses intentions et un
premier ministre qui ne cache plus ses
ambitions à l'assemblée l'examen du
budget 2010 fête se poursuit on a
beaucoup parlé des crédits des
ministères discussions dans un contexte
économique pour le moins difficile pour
le gouvernement et on va commencer cette
émission par la séquence politique on
commence par la primaire à droite
ce débat à droite a duré 2h45 il a été
plus vif que le premier marqué par des
passes d'armes entre les sept candidats
au centre des attaques
nicolas sarkozy mais françois bayrou a
aussi fait l'objet d'un long échange
égouttez participative je suis tout à
fait pour un projet qui rassemble la
droite et le centre
mais un centre qui est avec nous matin
midi et soir
pain sand qui demandent nos voix pour se
faire élire à pau et qu'il lendemain
refusent de voter la motion de censure
contre françois hollande et les
gouvernements qu'ils nomment aujourd'hui
il est carrément dans l'alternance
contre le pouvoir socialiste
il m'apporte son soutien contrairement à
tous les mensonges que j'entends dire je
ne lui ai rien promis et ne m'a rien
demandé je vais refuser son soutien des
petits mouvements sont je serais fait
d'attribuer karikari p ce serait
décevant terminer ce serait que débute
tout à fait suicidaire alors les
différents candidats se sont défendus de
parler de françois darroux et pourtant
il a quand même fait l'objet d'un trail
long échange
françois bayrou françois bayrou ce que
vous comprenez qu'on y lit a été accordé
autant d'attention au président du modem
écoutez moi ce que je constate dans ces
débats de la primaire de la droite c'est
qu'il n'y a pas vraiment de différence
sur les projets et donc on arrive à des
combats sur les personnes parce que sur
les projets on a pour tous les candidats
des projets extrêmement libéraux est
très destructeur pour les services
publics en particulier mais sur une
petit sourire sur la question-clé psg au
bateau de françois bayrou parce que ce
qui me braquer je sais ce que c'est un
beau chalet de cette primaire à droite
déjà on voit bien en tout cas que ça
devient un peu le mistigri c'est à dire
que nicolas sarkozy c'est de se repasser
le mistigri françois bayrou à alain
juppé qui s'en défend mais oui mais non
enfin ça me rappelle un petit peu les
heures les plus sombres des
affrontements rpr udf on a l'impression
qu'ils n'en sont pas sortis
finalement ça fait l'histoire de la
droite depuis des décennies c'est
toujours la même chose ils sont toujours
dans ses querelles sur le centre pas le
centre il avait fait une ump qui a été
finalement on le voit factice puisque on
revient à des discussions des polémiques
totalement totalement
ensuite c'est la même question vous s'il
y avait un gouvernement aujourd'hui on
vous propose de dettes dans ce
gouvernement et françois bayrou vous
accepter ça dépend quel gouvernement
quel programme quel projet moi je n'ai
rien j'ai pas du tout d'allergie à
françois bayrou
contrairement visiblement à nicolas
sarkozy qui développent de l'urticaire
rien 40 ans de son deux roues c'est la
droite mais il s'adapte mal françois
bayrou sur certaines choses par exemple
les institutions bon ou la moralisation
de la vie
il est très progressiste sur l'évolution
institutionnelle une dose de
proportionnelle
une laïcisation du rapport au pouvoir du
président de la république - de
monarchie c'est aussi dans la litanie
fiable c'est donc ce sont des idées que
je partage à tant sur l'aspect
économique je partage je ne partage pas
du tout ces questions là maintenant si
vous me demandez si en 2012 françois
hollande qui avait reçu le soutien de
françois bayrou aurait dû peut-être
soutenir françois bayrou à pau dans la
législative
alors bon écoutez je pense qu'en tout
cas la paix comme une erreur à cette
époque là si c'était pour faire la
politique qui là qu'il a fait ensuite
alors il pouvait tout à fait faire une
alliance avec françois bayroux puisque
finalement il était à peu près sur la
même ligne économique
il n'ya pas d'appétence pour les
programmes de la droite c'est à dire en
gros un choc libéral que promet la
grotte ça c'est ce qu'estime manuel
valls qu'il a raison pour vous je
constate en tout cas que manuel valls
n'est pas le mieux placé pour dire ça il
n'a dire qu'en fait quand on mène une
politique qui est quand même extrêmement
semblable en tout cas dans son
inspiration à une politique néolibérale
qui serait celle de la droite demain on
ne peut pas ensuite agité cet
épouvantail en disant attention la
droite revient voulez vous faire écouter
quand même un autre échange rapidement
c'est celui d'autres ne pâlit kosciusko
morizet et nicolas sarkozy écoute et oui
on a fait du bon travail je regrette
seulement qu'aujourd'hui cette manière
le grenelle de l'environnement ne
recrutant que lorient ne regrette pas ta
nomination est dans un environnement non
je ne suis pas sûr de le refaire mais je
ne regrette pas tendance à l'occasion du
grenelle de l'environnement
mais sa voix la seule femme courageuse
par rapport elle s'était approchée
sarkozy et des zones
elle a mis un petit peu de vie d'intérêt
dans ce débat au moins sur la question
écologique c'est vrai quel ami nicolas
sarkozy face à ses contradictions d'un
côté au front républicain également
salué la décision
c'est une constante chez elle elle a
toujours été très clairs là-dessus et et
moi je m'en félicite je l'en félicite en
tout cas donc je trouve qu'elle a une
certaine cohérence maintenant ce qui est
dommage c'est que ça aussi sur l'aspect
économique et sur l'aspect éducatif
c'est pas tellement novateur c'est pas
tellement moderne ce qu'elle propose
contrairement à son discours du
vainqueur pour vous de ce deuxième débat
ou pas non moi juge pas la pompe on est
mort on va regarder justement les bons
et les mauvais points chez vous cette
nouvelle séquence politique à gauche
et le climat est pour le moins tendu on
le prend le premier ministre et françois
hollande semaine glacial ils sont même
retrouvés on va tous avec elsa monaghan
après une semaine d'amabilités entre le
président de la république et son
premier ministre
l'heure semble être à l'apaisement
officiellement en tout cas je veux pas
faire comme si ça n'avait pas lieu mais
à chaque fois les choses
après que chacun ait pu dire ce qu'il
avait à dire les choses sont en ordre
je les dis un président qui a présidé et
après unis ce qui gouverne
mais dans la famille socialiste beaucoup
ont déjà choisi leur camp il y a ceux
qui défendent mordicus l'actuel chef de
l'état le temps de la campagne n'est pas
ouvert il donnera sa réponse au mois de
décembre est donc avant tout le reste et
hypothèses conjectures dessert de toute
façon
comment dire le projet mais l'action
collective donc ce qu'il faut c'est que
chacun revienne à sa tâche là où il est
il y en a d'autres qui ne sont pas
franchement convaincu par françois
hollande mais qu'ils le sont encore
moins par manuel valls est dans mon
courant on pourra sans doute avoir des
appels à voter pour tout candidat sauf
manuel valls et donc on n'est vraiment
pas du tout sûr quelqu'un qui
aujourd'hui a fait l'effort au cours des
dernières années pour rassembler la
gauche dans le camp d'en face certains
ont clairement choisi le premier
ministre ils ne veulent pas d'une
nouvelle candidature de françois
hollande on le voit bien quand on voit
un certain nombre de sondages
et quand on écoute nos concitoyens quand
on écoute aussi un certain nombre de nos
collègues députés
il ya un vrai problème est-ce qu'il est
encore aujourd'hui en situation
moi je le crois pas lui il peut pas
partir du principe que puisqu'il est
présent sortons notre présenter enfin il
ya ce qui renvoie dos à dos les deux
membres de l'exécutif
moi je vous soutiendrai notre
candidature il y aura un débat sur le
bilan et sur le projet et un débat de
fond politique ça c'est intéressant
c'est pour savoir si c'est brut us qui
peut remplacer césar ça ne m'intéresse
pas des députés socialistes divisés même
si pour l'instant aucun ne pense manuel
valls capable de se présenter contre
françois hollande aurélie filippetti
confirmez vous avoir rencontré cette
semaine claude bartolone et si oui est
ce qu'il ya une alliance pour empêcher
françois hollande connaît bien mais ça
va claude bartolone c'est le président
de l'assemblée qui recentre au député
cesser son rôle donc on le voulait en
venir à contrer et dans le cadre de ses
fonctions donc il n'y a pas d'alliances
et il n'ya pas d'avion pour empêcher
aujourd'hui thé des sujets parlementaire
et politique mais voilà on
on va travailler je pense que claude
bartolone s'est exprimé notamment sur le
livre qui fait beaucoup parler de lui en
fin ou françois hollande voit aussi
relation mais pour moi je le dis depuis
longtemps je pense que ce n'est pas un
problème un problème d'incarnation
d'ailleurs seulement c'est un problème
deux lignes politiques de cohérence par
rapport à une campagne et
maintenant ça devient vraiment un
problème pour l'ensemble du parti
ceux qui attendaient qu'il y ait ce
livre pour se rendre compte qu'il y a
quelque chose qui n'allait pas du tout
dans la politique menée et dans le monde
de françois hollande
il était un petit peu s'ouvre toujours
empêché françois hollande est candidat
c'est pas ça la question
la question c'est on a heureusement
obtenu une longue lutte qu'il y ait une
primaire à gauche on vient de parler de
la primaire à droite
je rappelle qu y aura une primaire à
gauche le 22 et 29 janvier donc c'est ça
le moyen démocratique et apaisé de
pouvoir désigner le candidat sont
évidemment l'ancien candidat pour
pouvoir s'exprimer
moi je ne je ne le souhaite ninja je ne
souhaite pas ou jeu mais je n'ai pas non
plus à nous c'est à lui de d'en décider
si vous voulez qu'ils le fassent au
qu'il le fasse qu'ils ne le fassent pas
pour moi la question françois hollande
appartient maintenant au passé alors je
serai dans l'aveyron que je considère
partir ou pas c'est françois hollande
appartient au passé et maintenant la
gauche doit tourner une nouvelle page et
cette nouvelle page elle doit commencer
avec la primaire de la gauche le new
york times évoque et qualifie françois
hollande de morts-vivants ça vous
inspire quoi
dans un long article non tribune écrite
et le trio va dire que new york times
soit inspirée par la gauche du parti
socialiste
donc ils font une analyse qui est et on
voit que peut-être qu'ils sont plus à
l'écouté finalement de la population
française que certains hiérarques de
solférino qui continuent de poser sur
françois hollande à se présenter
coûte que coûte alors restons sur ce
thème et je vous écoute et sept tasses
cet échange très vif qui a eu lieu à
l'assemblée pendant la question
gouvernement entre christian jacob et
manuel valls
écoutez savez vous ce qu'est un
sentiment d'abaissement et d'humiliation
qui résulte d'une atteinte à l'honneur
et à la dignité
ce sentiment c'est la définition de la
honte
cette honte que vous dit ressentir à
l'égard du président de la république
si vous pensez réellement ce que vous
avez dit vous auriez dû démissionner
dans ce moment là où
il y a tellement de doute tellement de
doutes sur la parole publique et le
débat qui est en train de se dérouler et
les attaques par exemple à l'égard de
françois bay où le rehausse pas me
semble-t-il
le débat sur jacob au lieu de rigoler au
lieu du rigolet au lieu d'interpeller au
lieu de mettre en cause
moi à ma place comme chef du
gouvernement je souhaite tout simplement
qu'il est de la dignité et que le
problème des responsables publics quel
qu'il soit c'est de redonner de la
fierté de l'espérance je vous laisse à
vos sarcasmes
moi je n'ai qu'une seule boussole la
france et la gauche talent de manuel
valls
est ce que pour vous il peut être un
recours pour la gauche non moi je ne
crois pas mais là encore si les s'il
souhaite se présenter il faut qu'ils se
présentent pas à la primeur tout
simplement il ya des candidats qui sont
d'ores et déjà clarifié sa position vous
pensez il le fera s'il souhaite se
démarquer du président de la république
mais il ne pourra pas s'exonérer de la
politique qui a été menée
encore une fois on je pense qu'il est
trop facile de dire que maintenant il ya
un problème françois hollande qui est un
problème uniquement de personnes c'est
un problème de politique menée et ça ne
date pas de souligner ça ne date pas de
la publication de ce livre métro
explique que vous disiez les gens tout à
l'heure où didier françois hollande
appartient au passé
est ce que fait maintenant de
l'indifférence vis-à-vis de françois
hollande à moi je pense que là
maintenant on entre dans une nouvelle
page on doit construire l'alternative
est l'alternative à gauche ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire se lancer dans le
processus de la primaire de la gauche
que françois hollande soit candidat dans
cette primaire ou pas de toute façon
s'il veut se représenter il doit passer
par cette primaire dont concentrons-nous
là dessus et moi je pense que les
électeurs de gauche veulent tourner
c'est ce que vous avez constaté comme
manuel valls une certaine colère et de
honte des militants socialistes mais
bien sûr évidemment un désarroi une
désespérance même et et ce livre a été
comme un révélateur il a mis des mots
sur un malaise qui était déjà palpable
avant sa publication
on va à présent accueillir notre
partenaire du scan du figaro c'est d'une
jarrassé aujourd'hui c'est l'heure de
votre chronique
bonjour aurélie filippetti on va parler
un peu de la campagne d'arnaud
montebourg son mot d'ordre en ce moment
c'est l'union de la gauche un peu comme
pascal fait mitterrand en son temps mais
avec quel périmètre c'est une question
importante le pcf se réunissent ce
week-end pour décider un peu de sa
stratégie en vue de la présidentielle
est-ce que vous souhaitez que les
communistes fasse un pas ce week-end
vers arnaud montebourg je pense que lui
l'arc l'arc en ciel en quelque sorte de
de la gauche il doit se reconstituer
parce que l'élection présidentielle
l'année prochaine va être difficile et
cet arc en ciel doit évidemment
comprendre les communistes les
écologistes des radicaux s'il arnaud
montebourg et les communistes pour au
cap à discussion de partie c'est pas on
n'est pas dans une logique d'appareil
on est dans une dans un travail sur une
construction d'une alternative une
alternative de gauche une politique de
gauche qui soit ambitieuse mais réaliste
et qui soit audacieuse qui soit moderne
donc on n'est pas sur la répétition du
passé de 1981 mais ce que je peux
constater en tout cas c'est que depuis
que françois hollande et manuel valls se
sont coupés d'une partie de leur
majorité
eh bien les choses n'ont fait qu aller
de mal en pis ils finissaient par
choisir jean luc mélenchon ce qui n'est
toujours pas exclu ce serait une erreur
de leur part
non c'est pas ce n'est pas une erreur
d'ailleurs la popularité de jean luc
mélenchon elle traduit bien le fait que
des gens aspirent à des valeurs de
gauche et à une politique de gauche donc
sont aujourd'hui
j verra bien comment on fait on verra
comment comment ça se passe encore une
fois n'ya pas de démarche d'appareil de
tractations de négociation c'est des
discussions sur des législatives n'ont
pas dit on est pas du tout là vous
parliez la popularité de jean luc
mélenchon en effet si on regarde les
sondages il frôle les 15 % d'intentions
de vote alors que arnaud montebourg
peine à atteindre les 10%
est-ce que c'est pas lui finalement jean
luc mélenchon la véritable alternative à
gauche à françois hollande
mais vous savez moi je me réjouis que
jean luc mélenchon soit haut dans les
sondages
encore une fois ça signifie simplement
qu'il y à une escalade des violences est
oui je pense et je pense surtout que
aujourd'hui on est au tout début même
peut-être avant la première étape du
processus de la primaire de la gauche
on ne sait pas quels seront les
candidats en présence au moment où on
sera dans la campagne de la primaire de
la gauche
déjà les choses seront plus claires il y
aura davantage aussi de débats il y aura
les moyens d'exposer ses idées et puis
après il y aura un candidat qui se
garent sur l'armée un nouveau va
peut-être accroître son ca popularité
c'est en tout cas celui qui celui qui
sera désignée par la primaire de la
gauche en janvier fin janvier il aura à
ce moment là avec lui derrière lui
qu'une dynamique une énergie qui lui
permettra de rentrer véritablement dans
la campagne présidentielle moins de
trois minutes vous avez cité tout à
l'heure les écologistes on connaîtra
leur candidat à la présidentielle lundi
soir le locle
est-ce que vous souhaitez que ce
candidat soit candidat à la primaire de
la gauche
moi j'aurais souhaité une primaire la
plus large peuvent toujours beau c'est
donc avec des écologistes jean luc
mélenchon mais voilà donc ce nom ce
n'est pas le cas maintenant s'ils
venaient dans notre primaire ça serait
formidable
est-ce qu'il faut un désaccord oui donc
je vais peut être qu'ils viennent oui
bien sûr on a bouffé le futur gagnant de
la primaire des verts
bien sûr j'aimerais que j'aimerais que
le futur candidat des verts participent
à la primaire de la gauche parce que ça
nous enrichirait et notamment sur les
questions environnementales on a
absolument besoin et aussi bien michèle
rivasi que yannick jadot sont des
experts en matière environnementale donc
on a besoin
un de ce savoir faire de cette cet
engagement au service surtout un accord
comme en 2012
les écologistes sur des mois je pense
que la gauche allait forte où et quand
elle et quand elle est rassemblé dans sa
diversité
ça veut dire pas d'union au forceps ça
veut dire le respect des sensibilités
des uns et des autres et surtout de la
place pour leurs idées et je suis ça la
modernité aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
ça la modernité aujourd'hui des sièges
ça dépendra aussi vous savez il ya des
choses qu'on partage à gauche c'est la
nécessité de réformer les institutions
et donc ça veut dire par exemple une
dose de proportionnelle qui permettra
une meilleure représentation des uns et
des autres
ça veut dire plus de pouvoir au
parlement ça veut dire en finir avec la
dyarchie à la tête de l'exécutif
un président un premier ministre ça ne
fonctionne pas bien qu'on est dans une
impasse
et ça on peint on a toutes ces valeurs
en commune et les oppose à la droite il
ya les questions institutionnelles ya
aussi le casus belli de notre dame des
landes hinault montebourg était en loire
atlantique cette fin il a dit que notre
âme de lang devait être mis en oeuvre
sans plus attendre un alain je précise
bien
il a rappelé qu'il avait été toujours
opposés et y compris quand il était
ministre à ce projet hilary là il a
exprimé à de nombreuses reprises et en
tant que ministre
son opposition à ce projet désormais il
faut que désormais il y a eu un vote
la différence c'est que l'on respecte
mais m il ya eu on est favorable moi je
suis très attaché à la démocratie
participative
il ya un référendum qui a organisé je
sais très bien que ce référendum
son périmètre n'a pas satisfait un
certain nombre de personnes néanmoins il
sait il a été réalisé le d'arnaud
montebourg vous même car je considère
moi je suis contre de cet aéroport et je
trouve que voilà mais aujourd'hui le
peuple s'est exprimé
et donc nous avons le devoir quand même
de respecter une volonté majoritaire qui
s'est exprimé d'une manière très claire
il ya eu une forte participation et il
ya eu une majorité nette
donc voyez c'est une on peut pas à la
fois défendre la démocratie
participative et en même temps ne
refuser le résultat d'un scrutin
quand il ne continuaient pas sur les
positions on a défendu et encore une
fois moi j'aurais été totalement
défavorable ce projet aurait dû être
arrêtée au début du quinquennat
merci du jas ces concepts
séquence politique et on va passer un
autre troisième thème parlementaire
l'examen du budget l'examen du plf 2010
est comme on l'appelle se poursuit à
l'assemblée avec le volet dépenses
un débat qui se tient dans un contexte
économique un peu compliqué pour le
gouvernement rim benameur c'est un
revirement
le gouvernement admet enfin que la
croissance n'atteindra pas 1,5 pour cent
en 2016 après l'avoir martelé pendant
des mois dans le compte rendu du conseil
des ministres cette phrase le reconnaît
il est possible que la croissance en
2016 soit légèrement plus faible que
prévu mais ceci n'est pas inquiétant pas
d'inquiétude
c'est ce que répète michel sapin même
s'il est forcée de revoir son chiffre à
la baisse sera difficile d'atteindre à 5
donc ce sera quelque part entre 1 3 et à
sac la croissance en france a repris
d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
les créations d'emplois les créations
d'emploi nettes ont repris en france ait
eu 130 mille créations d'emplois dans le
secteur privé mais 0,1 pour cent de
croissance en moins c'est 2 milliards
d'euros en moins dans les caisses de
l'état et les dépenses elles augmentent
la droite s'inquiète pour les prochaines
années
le budget 2010 est qui est très critique
parce que d'une part il reporte
énormément de charges sur 2018 et les
années ultérieures
et d'autre part il est construit sur une
prévision de croissance à 1,5 qui bon
compte tenu des performances de 2016
risque de ne pas se produire
autre difficulté pour le gouvernement
tenir l'objectif de baisse du déficit
premier à bruxelles
pour l'instant il s'engage toujours à
passer sous la barre des 3,3 pour cent
alors bruxelles doit rendre son avis
très bientôt sur ce sur ce budget
français est ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut s'attendre un avertissement il ya
beaucoup de cadeaux beaucoup de
promesses on a du mal à voir avec une
croissance aussi faible
comment toutes ces promesses peuvent
être tenues qu'est ce que vous en pensez
que je pense que c'est la preuve que ces
règles sont totalement absurdes et
deviennent même dangereuse pour
l'économie française pour l'économie des
pays européens autres que l'allemagne
il faut en finir avec ces règles là et
c'est bien ça d'ailleurs le coeur je
pense de ce qui doit être le débat de la
présidentielle en 2017
finalement ce qu'on a fait depuis 2012
c'est essayer de diminuer un déficit
public et de diminuer une dette publique
d'une manière drastique
au moment où le pays était à peine
convalescent après la grave crise de
et ça ça a failli c'est le remède qui
tue le malade en vue d'une sortie
ç'a failli nous tuer ça fait tuer toute
l'europe continentale encore une fois à
l'exception de l'allemagne mais est
encore donc longue changer l'air il faut
changer ses règles
maintenant si vous me demandez si la
prévision de croissance du gouvernement
était réaliste non a été surestimée mais
ça on le savait on savait des ddd
l'année dernière et
donc bon c'est malheureusement pas
forcément pas forcément une surprise
il fallait je pense avoir une politique
budgétaire beaucoup plus souple dès 2012
c'est ce que disait tous les économistes
en tout cas là dans la musique vous avez
obtenu sous la pression de l aile gauche
il ya eu beaucoup des députés en général
de valérie rabault aussi il ya des
choses qui ont été obtenus notamment sur
la taxe sur les transactions financières
vous a faite au comptant à l'orgue
hammond lâche on a lâché beaucoup de
choses on le gouvernement a lâché un
certain nombre de choses sur la taxe sur
transactions financières et pour
permettre de financer l'aide publique au
développement aussi une augmentation de
260 millions d'euros de cette aide
publique au développement
ce qui est extrêmement important parce
qu'on parle par exemple la situation des
migrants qui arrivent sur nos côtes mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour aider les pays
en développement et donc pour leur
permettre de créer des emplois pour
éviter que les gens n'aient besoin de
fuir
je parle là des migrants économiques et
pas de ce qui fut la guerre donc c'est
sa célèbre votre non moi je me suis
abstenu sur sur la première partie
donc j'ai voté en revanche un certain
nombre de crédits notamment ceux de
lettres de reculer loppement je pense
que je m'abstiendrai parce que malgré
tout il ya quand même aussi un certain
nombre de problèmes de de sincérité dans
ce budget puis je pense que c'est pas de
la bonne politique de lâchers en quelque
sorte en fin de quinquennat
alors qu'on a fait des économies quand
on a essayé de serrer la ceinture
beaucoup trop violemment au début on va
terminer cette émission par deux
questions importantes l'une que je vais
vous poser sur ce fichier qui a été
publiée par le vice à l'intérieur qui
compile des données personnelles et
biométriques de de nous tous de tous les
français dans une seule base unique est
ce que pour vous le c'est un problème
pour les libertés fondamentales surtout
si ce fichier se retrouve dans les mains
de dans notre gouvernement par exemple
c'est un problème essentiel je suis très
inquiète sur ce fichier et sur les
réponses que le gouvernement apporte aux
questions qui sont posées par les
députés là dessus car le gouvernement ne
dit pas la vérité quand il dit que la
cnil
oui il ya une question nous a demandé
qui par la vérité nan parce que la
présidente de la cnil madame falque
perrotin a indiqué qu'elle avait
elle-même de grandes inquiétudes
notamment sur le contrôle qui pouvait
être fait de ce fichier c'est à dire que
elle souhaite qu'il y ait un comble
la mairie terre il a menti il a prétendu
que la cnil était d'accord avec ces
friches et or ce n'est pas le cas la
présidente de la cnil a dit que les
contre pouvoirs n'était pas suffisant et
notamment qu'elle souhaitait qu'il y ait
un contrôle parlementaire beaucoup dansé
la retraite quoi selon vous
mais je vous devrez rentrer des quoi je
pense que il faut absolument revoir la
manière dont on va contrôler
l'utilisation de ce fichier et que
notamment le pouvoir des parlementaires
soient renforcées mais il faut en tout
cas écouter la présidente de la cnil
aurélie filippetti et autres questions
d'actualité vous avez été ministre de la
culture le csa a mis en demeure la
chaîne d'information i télé alors que la
rédaction est toujours en grève pour
manquements donne était de rigueur
elle s'en prend directement la direction
de cette chaîne vous soyez ministre
encore de la culture aujourd'hui vous
feriez quoi pour cette chaîne va écouter
je pense que on voit bien que les les
chartes éthiques et tous les engagements
qui sont pris par les patrons de chaînes
sont parfois des lettres mortes
moi je pense qu'il faut renforcer c'est
ce que j'avais essayé de faire en tant
que ministre c'est extrêmement difficile
je dois le dire l'indépendance des
rédactions il faut donner une véritable
indépendance
le départ inattendu cette rédaction pour
leur donner la force de pouvoir résister
à leurs actionnaires
c'est ça aujourd'hui l'enjeu donc
premièrement renforcer l'indépendance
des rédactions et 2 je veux dire
l'indépendance juridique c'est à dire
permettre aux sociétés de journalistes
d'être véritablement des personnes
juridiquement autonome de leurs
actionnaires et deuxièmement ça veut
dire aussi qu'il faut qu'on s'attaque
enfin ce qu'on n'a pas pu faire pendant
ce quinquennat mais à la concentration
de la propriété d'un certain nombre de
grands groupes de presse
elle avoue qu'on voit passer directement
au patron mais il est aujourd'hui
dépassée semblerait pas seulement
bolloré mais on voit aujourd'hui qu'il y
a quatre ou cinq personnes extrêmement
riche en france qui détiennent des
chaînes
oui des chaînes de télévision des
journaux et qu'il ya des empires de
presse écrite et audiovisuelle qui se
sont créés et qu'ils ne sont pas
indépendants et du pouvoir et dans celle
de quoi sont d'abord monsieur abbas est
une grande menace sur l'information
c'est une grande menace sur la liberté
démocratique
ici on a de la chance parce qu'on est
sur une chaîne indépendante parce
qu'elle est totalement totalement public
et heureusement donc quand vous prenez
la jeune comité vais parler aujourd'hui
n'est pas indépendante
on finira sur ses leaders en tout cas je
considère les journalistes font preuve
d'une qu'un grand courage d'une grande
indépendance je les salue et je les
soutiens
parce qu'en plus ils sont évidemment
menacé de représailles dans leur
carrière elles doivent pas lâcher ils ne
doivent pas lâcher et continuer la grève
et heureusement que le cs a enfin pris
cette décision mais maintenant il ya un
problème c'est comment on fait pour que
l'on ne puisse pas avoir ainsi d empire
audiovisuel et de presse écrite qui se
constituent dans les mains de puissances
qui sont des puissances économiques
oui filippetti pendant le cours de cette
émission n'a appris que pierre laurent
était favorable donc c'est le patron du
parti communiste est favorable à la
candidature de jean luc mélenchon
l'ordre a peu parlé tout à l'heure
comme la formation vient de nous
parvenir est ce que vous pouvez
commenter cette information mais écoutez
moi je suis un soutien du pc évidemment
la candidature
enfin je ne sais pas exactement ce qui a
été dit et des cars et enfin jean pierre
laurent n'a jamais été opposé à la
candidature de jean-luc mélenchon et et
le parti communiste n'était pas engagée
dans la démarche des primaires de la
gauche ça me reprend pas cette non ça me
surprend pas maintenant on verra comment
comment les discussions c'est en tout
cas ça n'obère pas l'avenir pour la
suite
après les primaires de la gauche et pour
la constitution d'un rassemblement qui
permettent d'avoir une gauche en bon
état à l'élection le retour de sergio
pour une discussion avec les caméras
mais je crois qu'il ya des nuits les
discussions sont pas closes
il n'y a pas vous savez on n'est pas
comme avec françois bayrou du côté de la
droite on n'est pas en train de te dire
on veut pas de jean luc mélenchon c'est
pas du tout ça
mais jean-luc mélenchon et d'autre les
verts voilà allez les radicaux c'est
comme ça que la gauche peut être forte
quand elle est unie dans sa diversité
merci à merci c'était la fin de cette
émission vous retrouve pas la semaine
prochaine à cause du pont du 11 novembre
semaine suivante contre est une suite de
programmes sur chaîne parlementaire bail